hey guys thanks tuning in say recently
added video I'm a deaf no and that went
down quite well that's the real
limitless pill the new trick designed to
boost your brainpower so I thought I'd
discuss another new trick this time
called practing which is possibly the
most popular and atrophic that many who
use especially completely safe and is
available off the shelf without
prescription and marketed as things like
neutrophils so it actually is this one's
designed it allows to be a new trick so
let's have a look at whether it works
and why think about it from my
experiences
so basically throughout the town
enhances your brain's ability to use a
substance called acetylcholine which is
a neurotransmitter it was the first view
of transmitter discovered and it's used
for your neurons communicating with each
other and has been implicated in memory
it's also been shown to do a number of
other things to the brain it seems to
increase the oxygen consumption which
suggests that your brain is working
extra hard so now it also apparently may
improve the NMDA receptors which has
also been implicated in memory but it's
not 100% fully understood what the
mechanisms of action are which you
should always be a little bit wary of
where you get stuff like that because
you know early tests are showing there's
no side effects and many people find it
very useful for improving their memory
as well as their reading comprehension
and other people about different effects
they list such as being more eloquent
when they speak etc but unfortunate for
a lot of other people it doesn't work
many people say there have been no
effect so if there are effects they're
very subtle and brain fog and headaches
seem to be common - despite the official
word being that there's no side effects
that it's completely safe it's non-toxic
so and how you liver but it does seem
that some people are having negative
experiences because of the brain fog and
their headaches and hopefully that's not
going to help you to be particularly
more productive in fact I'll go grab the
adverse effect and in fact some people
are saying that even after they stop
taking crack of town they still have the
same problem so that's something to be a
little bit wary off you take the town's
recommend that you also supplement with
extra : that's the substance found in
eggs it's the precursor acetylcholine so
your brain is using more a Tatar choline
you need it to be able to create more
and have more available which is where
you give it the coton and otherwise they
will use it all up and that's one reason
you get headaches but many people
supplement with extra choline and they
still find they have headaches what
about my experiences as well I have
headaches
at this rate Fox so that wasn't great
although I found that actually sometimes
want to take Cohen I get headaches
anyway it's just on its own I think my
brain has got excess Haley and I passed
out
there's a supple skin evening
yeah
I think some people are wanting to be
the case it's not actually the case in
my experience in front of people
expectancy person that's not to say that
the Z boson worthwhile yourselves I mean
if it works it works doesn't matter how
it works
you can knowingly yourself
what
you can change what you're thinking to
change the body chemistry
I think personally the to me the
benefits they've ruled anything to
outweigh the potential negatives even if
it's unlikely you can have a negative
reaction it's fairly high chance you're
gonna get pretty [ __ ] headaches and
just to waste your money and you don't
really know what you're doing the team
range so do I recommend it not not I
know there's many different things you
can do to boost brainpower a lot more
safely things like extra sleep exercise
brain training exercises some of which I
like some of which I don't we can go
into that later but yeah point is you're
kind of its kind of like bashing the
radio to fix it you don't really you
know might work but you don't really
know what you're doing and it's not
technically engineering is it
there's the saintly brain on me just
poking around that adding different
compounds not really knowing the subtle
effects they could be having on your
brain so for me rocket town even though
it's a relatively modern unless they
don't try it is supposed to be safe but
you know I'm not also gonna give it a
rating of you because for me or what
made it was of course quite headaches
and other people seem to have the same
experience my favorite new trade pick
for boost in memory in the tension is
good old cup of tea and that's a lot
more delicious as well anyways thanks
for watching
there's my thoughts on crack down and
have different experiences I'd love to
hear from you obviously so let me know
in the comments I'll be discussing some
of my other methods of boosting brain
power subsequently on this channel so
stay tuned if you'd like to hear more
about that thanks for watching
I'll catch you next time